لم تعرف حتى اللحظه هويه مطلق النار على
الكتيبه الايرلنديه العامله في القوه
الامميه المؤقته جنوب لبنان ما عرف فقط هو
ان الهجوم نفذ باستخدام رشاش الحربي اطلقت
منه سبع رصاصات على اليه تابعه للكتيبه
بحسب معلقه وكاله فرانسبريس عن مصدر
القضائي احدى الرصاصات اصابت راس السائق
من الخلف ما ادى الى وفاته واصابه ثلاثه
اخرين بجروح العرب ارتطم تعرضها لاطلاق
نار بعمود حديدي ثم انقلبت وفق المصدر
الذي اكد ان القضاء العسكري وضع يده على
التحقيق وان القوه الامنيه تطارد اشخاصا
يشتبه بعلاقتهم بالحادثه متوقعا ان يبدا
تحقيق مشترك مع قوات اليونيفيل كون
الاجهزه اللبنانيه غير مخوله بالاستماع
الى عناصر قوه الامم المتحده وندد مسؤولون
اللبنانيون بما جرى وعلى راسهم رئيس حكومه
تصريف الاعمال نجيب ميقاتي الذي ابدى اسفه
للحادثه فيما تقدم مسؤوله وحده تنسيق
والارتباط في حزب الله بالتعزيه لقوات
اليونيفيل داعيا الى عدم اقحام الحزب وترك
المجال للاجهزه الامنيه للتحقيق ولم توجه
التهابات رسميه لاي طرف لكن البعض اعاده
تذكير بكلام الامين العام لحزب الله لقوات
اليونيفيل قبل اشهر عندما حذر القوه
الامميه من عواقب العمل بعيد عن الدوله
والجيش اللبناني وقوه اليونيفع الموجوده
في لبنان منذ العام
1978 وتضم نحو عشره الاف جندي وتنتشر جنوب
لبنان للفصل بينه وبين اسرائيل بعد نزاعات
عده